[Musique]
mais un retour en direct avec vous mais
l'anip ok bon soir avec vous on va
découvrir ce soir la commanderie
autrement le site saint quentinois va se
retrouver ce week end au centre d'un
événement particulier c'est un coup de
coeur
cette semaine qui connaît des
turbulences des ambulances mais elles
sont ces turbulences c'est en fait le
nom de la création tout droit sorti de
l'imagination d'une chorégraphe ça va
peut-être rappeler quelque chose à nos
téléspectateurs
ah oui oui nous aviez parlé d'un sujet
en mai de ce sujet en mai dernier
à l'époque c'est la chorégraphe tatiana
julien et et la commanderie qui
recherchait des intéressés une quinzaine
d'entre eux a répondu présent ils
viennent d'un peu partout de
l'agglomération de 50 en une et même de
paris depuis se sont retrouvés en juin
pour créer tout cela on voit les
journées de travail à l'image il fallait
appréhender le travail de tatiana julien
mais aussi comprendre comment la
commanderie peut devenir un lieu
chorégraphique c'est de créer un projet
très immersif très plein de liberté et
de joie est quelque chose d'assez festif
avec le public où il ya une première
déambulation le public circule librement
dans tout le bâtiment ils visitent le
bâtiment mais par la danse les
spectateurs vont des vont donc être
accompagnés de danseurs professionnels
et amateurs mais pas seulement mais pour
cette découverte ou la redécouverte de
la commanderie seront équipés d'un
casque audio ils pourront ainsi écouter
des flux musique musicaux différents
mais aussi des réflexions sur l'art et
la danse alors tatiana tatiana julien
avait déjà créé une turbulence au
château de vincennes je propose
maintenant d'écouter fanny debré les
chargés du développement artistique du
site saint quentinois et elle nous
explique ce qui les a attiré dans ce
projet on a été complètement emporté
voilà emballé par cette proposition
puisque on n'est pas dans une
représentation classique avec le public
d'un côté
le spectacle de l'autre la la danse elle
est partout alentour
le spectateur est niveau du sensation et
en plus à la commanderie c'est un lieu
fait pour des propositions inédites
original singulière alors la commanderie
et s'anime le 6 juillet prochain début
des turbulences à 21h et la soirée après
la déambulation c'est un concert dansé
au son électro d'accès de rigaud merci
mélanie pour cette chronique comme
d'habitude vous serez à la présentation
du 7-8 culture c'est dans un instant sur
tv 78